Now you might be asking yourself what's the difference between something like
exploratory data analysis and data visualization.
In the previous diagram I drew a pretty big distinction between the two, but
to students new to visualization, they can often seem very similar.
Chris, how would you describe the difference between EDA and
something like data visualization?
>> Yeah I think of it as the difference between notes and lecture.
It is a conversation between yourself and the data.
While data visualization is a conversation between data and your audience.
>> Yeah, I think Kathy O'Neil puts it
really well in her book Doing Data Science.
She says that EDA is what happens between you and
your data when you're not trying to do prove anything to anyone yet.
When I get a piece of data,
the first thing I do is make some basic plots, scatter plots, histograms and
things like that, and it's important for a variety of reasons.
Let's look at one now.